bonjour vous ne regardiez faire je suis
en train d'installer une boîte aux
lettres avec toutes les lettres de voeux
pour les fêtes de fin d'année et les
lettres au père noël
ce qui sera bien utile sur l'île pas
vrai bonjour factor oh vous installer
une boîte aux lettres et bien ça c'est
une valider un ça nous évitera de faire
du chemin pour poster nos lettres je
suis bien content de voir que cela votre
part est utile par way depuis quelques
jours le courrier il ya beaucoup de
courrier un regard de mon sac
il est plein à craquer pas voir là là
avait dit non ça doit être du travail 1
pour trier tout ça ou pour sur oger des
collègues qui travaillent toute la nuit
pour trier et pour renvoyer dans votre
voulu le tout le courrier
ah c'est pas toujours nos paroles c'est
certain en tout cas et les jolies votre
teint si vous voyez l'intérieur pour sûr
montrez-moi attendait c'est un véritable
bijou c'est le dernier modèle est un peu
dure à ouvrir enfin il vaut mieux il
vaut mieux bien protégé le courrier
c'est sacré pareil pour suivre ah voilà
c'est beau un super et voilà aller au
bar était bon on vous avez 1000 il va
falloir que j'ouvre à nouveau cette
boîte aux lettres les elle est difficile
à ouvrir les excuser moi fekter geste
idiot j'ai jamais pas réfléchi ça faut
toujours se méfier des gestes qu'on fait
sans réfléchir et voir allez c'est pas
bien grave
tout le monde fait des erreurs pendant
l'ère aussi et c'est parfois bien c'est
leur dispenser cette gaine mon avis
n'est ce pas voilà voilà
et encore pardon on va effecteur c'est
rien c'est rien allez on va françois
mais ça semblait une bonne idée d'avoir
un stage tchad
bonjour j j'ai pensé que ça vous ferait
moins de chemin
pas mal et puis je vais en profiter tout
de suite parce qu'à ma copine juliette
qatar était encore falloir quelques
jours c'est cette boîte aux lettres elle
est très difficile en riant je suis
désolé c'est aussi contente de
l'inaugurer aubin vous savez ce matin
elle a été bien inaugurer un ça fait
trois fois que tu es jaloux je la refais
ben voila je lis votre lettre partira
aujourd'hui
ne vous inquiétez pas on voir en valais
et bonne journée
casimir avec lui je n'ai pas envie
d'ouvrir encore une fois cette boîte aux
lettres pas vrai bonjour factor je vois
une nouvelle boîte à elle est très jolie
vous venez de l'installer oui casimir
vient ici pourquoi pourquoi
non mais ne profite pas de la boîte aux
lettres un set c'est dangereux mais non
non non non non non non
casimir vient pierre revient
m va partir mais nos jours je ne voulais
pas que tu la mettre dans la boîte bas
depuis ce matin mais ça fait trois fois
que j'enlève des lettres à là dedans
là dedans alors c'est beaucoup pour
aujourd'hui par r je ne voulais pas la
mettre dans la boîte
c'est une lettre que vous m'avez donné
hier qui vient de ma tante adélaïde je
n'avais pas lu encore attendre à dire
c'est une lettre qui a été adressée mois
et alors au mieux il va falloir que je
que je regarde dans tout ce sac que
j'enlève tout le courrier
c'est terrible pour une fois c'est moi
qui n'ai pas réfléchi pas vrai
[Musique]